max freed is on the mound coming off
jeff a terrific return for the injure
list against the nationals need more of
the same from him tonight yeah his last
13 home games chipped 9-1 with the 3-1-3
here at truest park and on the ground to
third
riley's got it plays patty cake and
throws a strike
and that's when max free jeff is at his
best he's gonna get his strikeouts
but he is a terrific ground ball pitcher
too
and it's served in right but acuna good
job
and he can't hang on but shed around
first big turn
akunya throws back to first and they got
him
machetes going to stand at first and
appeal this play he thought he got the
hand back
acuna with a strike to freddie freeman
he applied the tag the call at first is
out let's see if he was
a little bit of a slip tag on the
collarbone and pachette said he was safe
see here and he is out base is empty
he jumps on the first pitch roller
toward third riley's throw
is on the money max freed breezes
through the first inning with a little
help from the cannon of ronald acuna
junior in right
yeah make his seventh start of the
season he's coming off his second win
last time out against oakland he
returned off the eye out he had that
strained glute muscle
and he gets acuna swinging to begin the
bottom of the first
freddie freeman first pitch swinging
pops one up for buchet
and quickly two down here's a bouncer to
third
biggio will play it the short way to
force the lead runner
and that'll be that one inning in the
books in atlanta no score
this kind of worked for the brave
starting pitching staff now takes on
added importance with the bad news we
got on mike soroka today exploratory
surgery isn't
is required for mike something not quite
right he says with the achilles
as biggio drives one toward left center
and it's gonna be he makes the play
swing at a miss
max freed has his first strikeout
no score to the bottom of the third
it'll be panchay freed and acuna for the
braves during the third inning
and he makes quick work of pache for his
fourth strike out of the night already
you know what ryu i mean he'll carve up
this part of the lineup for you just 35
pitches so far
and the o2 will get him swinging he
strikes out freeman on three pitches
five strikeouts through three scoreless
innings for ryu
max freed has faced the minimum through
his first three frames with a strikeout
and he pulled a string on him a
curveball
back-to-back strikeouts for max freed
and simeon limps back to the toronto
dugout
see the sharp break that spin rate for
max
way up there get some out front for
reasons
we we do not know at this moment
vladimir guerrero jr is using a marcel
ozuna bat
in this game maybe saw him hit a home
run with it and stole it
could be 1-1 pitch fly ball hit toward
left how about that
ozuna's bat and ozuna makes the catch
and that retires the side freed rolling
along
we're still scoreless william contreras
leading off the fifth inning for atlanta
and a drive no doubt about that one how
far is that going
halfway up the bleachers contreras goes
deep
and the braves strike first on a leadoff
solo homer
well sorry max you no longer have the
hardest ball of the night
contreras gets a hanging change up and
absolutely hammers it
halfway up the left field seats that is
a long way on a cold night
yes with the wind blowing toward right
second homer for
contreras fifth homer allowed by ryu and
the braves
have the game's first run the o2
and a swing and a miss ryu strikes him
out again but atlanta takes the lead on
the home run by william contreras
one-nothing braves at the end of five
now freed will try to mow him down here
in the sixth inning there he goes though
swinging a miss and no throw from
contreras and biggio
will steal second two down one two pitch
and a curveball hit hard to left field
and that's going to get to the fence
biggio will come into score easily
and simeon is on his way to second base
with an rbi double that has tied the
game
well marcus hasn't really hit that well
against breaking balls all season long
but boy he got a nice curveball to hit
right there and remember the curveball
earlier in the about that looked like he
was just a bit out of the zone and this
one stays
right over the heart of the plate and he
hammers it
fly ball hitting the air toward left
center and
pache is there guerrero just missed
and freed is out of the sixth inning a
leadoff walk comes home to roost
toronto's tied the game 1-1
and luke jackson will come on for
atlanta
for the year luke is 1-0 with a 138 era
in 14 games
and oscar swings at the first pitch
sends it to d
bright center field gone
and just like that the blue jays have
taken the lead
how about the oscar liking the offering
he sees on the first pitch from
luke jackson and boy did he square it up
couple of long home runs here in this
ball game contreras for the braves and
now te oscar hits his fourth of the
season
he had a big three-hit game last night
he smokes this ball
deep center field now the braves has to
go to work against ryu who's back out
there with the lead
and this wall is line to center but it's
lined right at randall grichik and it's
a one two three bottom of the seventh
what an outing denied by hyunjin ryu
josh tomlin will come on
and face the jays in the ninth inning
oscar gets into one hits it deep left
field it's gone
his second home run of the night and it
is four to one blue jays
well we talked about a couple extra runs
and the oscar took it into his own hands
his second home run and the fan throws
it back onto the field
but boy oh boy you talk about a big
cushion coming here in the ninth
fifth home run second of the night forte
oscar and the smiles are all around
and say hello to aj cole he's now
pitching out of this terrific toronto
bullpen
and now the 2-2 golf to center field but
right there is jonathan davis one down
reuse seven innings a run on five hits
chat with a perfect eighth and now cole
in the nine
in the 02 swanson reaches for it lifts a
fly ball to center field lots of room
for davis
and that's the second out first pitch
a swing and a fly ball to left hit
fairly well
tay oscar back he's got room and he
makes the catch
and the blue jays will beat the braves
for the second
night in a row a couple of home runs for
hernandez
and outstanding pitching tonight for the
blue jays
as they get to three games over 500 for
the first time this season